TOMER SHARON: Welcome everyone.
We're going to talk today
about not listening to users,
about sampling their experience.
Three years ago, I started
working in a Google Search.
Before that I worked in an
Ads for 2 and 1/2 years,
and we started getting more and
more interested in what people
want to know,
because what you saw
in the video is what people
actually do on Google.
Of course it's a
parody, but this
is what people actually do.
We wanted to know what
they want to know,
with or without
connection to Google.
So a team came to me and
we started planning this,
and since then we've
been doing a study that's
we call internally DIN that
stands for Daily Information
Needs.
And this has been going
on since then in the US
and in other countries
around the world.
What we pretty much ask
our study participants
is this question-- what did
you want to know recently?
And we ask this
question over and over
again during a few days.
And we ask a lot of people,
we ask this question.
We even have t-shirts
for the DIN project
internally at Google.
Hi, my name is Tomer Sharon.
I'm a Google Search user
experience researcher,
and today we're going to
talk about a method called
Experience Sampling.
The problem, I want to
start and talk a few minutes
about the problem that we have.
The problem is that
people listen to users.
What I call is to not
listen to people's opinions
or ask them any question
about the future.
Would you use something?
Instead, I call for
observing behavior.
And I want to talk a
little bit about why.
I don't listen to
users because of what
I know about the psychology
of the difference
or the relationship between
attitude and behavior.
Attitude is what
people say they do
and behaviors is what
they actually do.
Here's one study.
This was done in 1937.
The researcher went into
classrooms and asked students,
would you cheat in an exam?
And they answered.
A few weeks after that, got
back to the same students
and together with
the teachers, they
were giving these students
an opportunity to cheat
without them knowing that
they're being tracked.
And surprise,
surprise, there was
close to zero correlation
between what people said
about their future behavior
and their actual behavior.
This was 1937.
That's 77 years ago.
Here's something from 2012.
Researchers in the
UK-- and this was
done with dozens of
thousands of people
in the UK-- went into public
bathrooms in gas stations
all over the country,
and they asked
people coming out
of the bathroom
did you wash your hands after
you finish your business?
And 99% of people said yes.
However, they also installed
electronic recording devices
inside the bathrooms,
and they actually
counted how many people
wash their hands.
And again, 32% of
men and 64% of women
really did wash their hands.
Now there are many reasons
why this is happening.
Lying is not one of them.
OK, usually people are
not intentionally lying
about their behavior.
We're just very bad
at predicting it.
Now I want to take you
into the start-up world.
I've been interviewing a lot of
people in the start-up world,
and what I found is this.
This is the main finding--
entrepreneurs have no time
or budget to spend on
learning from users.
This is what I observed.
And I interviewed 150
start-up founders and VCs
because I was so surprised by
what I heard from start-ups,
and I also talked with VCs
and I was even more depressed.
But, I want to share the
other primary findings
from these interviews.
Only 12% of them knew
what is user experience.
And I was very generous.
I asked them a direct
question-- in your opinion, what
is the definition
of user experience?
And they gave me their answer.
I was very generous in
evaluating their responses,
and even after this
generosity only 12% of them
really knew, defined
it very well.
Another finding--
a start-up idea
is born from a
founder's personal pain.
86% of start-up founder's
start their start-up
because they had a problem.
OK, now it's not necessarily a
bad thing, it's just a finding.
It could be bad if
they're convinced
that the entire world
has this problem.
In many cases, they are
convinced that this is so.
I also asked what
are other reasons
that you started your start-ups.
This is what I found.
So personal pain, 86%.
And user research is
down there with 2%,
meaning that they did research
to identify user needs,
and then they came up with an
idea based on what they found.
In between, spin off.
They started a company and
then pivoted or changed it
completely or started a new
company based on what they did.
Requests from clients,
clients came to them
and ask them for something
and they started a company,
or they read market
research reports.
But the main result
here is that it's solely
based on personal pain.
What I saw is that
ideas are mostly
for products or services.
There was close to 0% of
the people I interviewed
who thought about a
problem, a problem to solve,
and started with this.
Here's a company that
didn't think about a problem
before they started, and
you can clearly see that.
Who knows what this is,
except for that it's a phone.
Yeah.
It's a jitterbug phone.
What's special about
the jitterbug phone?
It's for older people who
have a hard time reading.
I agree.
It's even more than just
a hard time reading.
They have big buttons here.
It's not the size of the phone,
but it's not far from it.
It's really, really big.
The letters, the
font is really big.
There's this cover here.
All of this-- can you think
why they're doing this?
Why are all these
special features?
What is the prior knowledge?
A phone for complete novices.
They don't know--
[INAUDIBLE]
They have no need or concept
of modern smart phones, yes.
AUDIENCE: They have
real physical needs--
TOMER SHARON: They have
real physical needs
for different types
of interfaces.
Why?
I argue that there is,
for every new product,
there's prior
knowledge that people
apply to using this new product.
What is the prior
knowledge of elderly people
when they use this?
[INAUDIBLE]
That's a problem.
What is their knowledge?
[INAUDIBLE]
Push button land line.
I would go even further back.
This is their prior knowledge.
Now let's compare these.
Big font.
And there's a thing--
how many of you
saw elderly people use
a smartphone like this?
You saw that?
That's for a reason.
That's the reason.
Because it worked this way.
It reached their mouth and ear.
And this is what they did here.
This cover here,
this grey cover here,
is to block the noise exactly as
you could have done with this.
And there are
other features that
are just easier
for people to use.
It's not based on
prior knowledge,
but it's based on knowledge
that they don't have.
Everything here is
yes/no questions.
They type, they dial the number,
and then it asks them, call?
And there are two
yes no buttons.
So it's all very kind
of conversational.
So they don't need to
understand if you remember
the buttons back then--
send, end, or figure out
different icons
and what they mean.
So this is based
on fundamentally
understanding a problem.
These are the questions
app developers and startup
founders ask themselves.
These are great questions
that they ask themselves.
97% ask who are my customers.
95% ask a critical question--
do people need my product?
And 89% ask if the
product is usable
or not, and other questions.
But this is the problem--
the way people answer
their great questions
is extremely
invalid and
unreliable, and I want
to share some of these answers,
and some of them are funny
but they well
represent the answers I
got in 150 interviews.
Who are my customers?
The way they answer it is
analytics and assumptive
personas.
They invent personas.
Inventive personas
are personas that
are based on nothing, based
on intuition not on research.
Analytics, they go
through demographics
and this is how they know
who their customers are.
Do people need my product?
Again a critical
question, and there
are ways to answer
it with research.
This is how the answer
it, and I'm not kidding.
Is the product usable?
We focus on UX.
We really, really, really,
really focus on UX,
meaning that it's good.
We use it ourselves
is another answer.
We know if it's usable or not.
We need the founders,
we the company.
Is our product better
than the competition?
After a 10 minute argument
that they have no competition
and me saying that they
do have competition
without even knowing them,
they agree and answer,
we do things differently.
We can't compare.
And if we can compare,
we compare feature lists.
We look at the
competitions website
and we see a long
list of features.
We compare it to ours and
then we know who's better.
Is our product getting better?
We improve it all
the time, so yes.
And do people want the product?
Which is, by the way, a
question I'm not really
suggesting you ask
because what people want
doesn't really matter.
What matters is what they need.
And it's always different.
And I kid here, but
this is what they
do-- they ask friends
and family members.
And friends and family
members are very nice to you.
They want you to succeed.
But they're really biased.
So that's a problem.
All of this means
one thing-- that's
a huge risk that they're taking.
A huge risk.
He's not going to
catch him, right?
And these start-ups
develop products
that nobody, nobody needs.
And they're executing
the wrong plan.
You, you came here.
I know you never do that, right?
But just in case you do,
I want to introduce you
to Experience Sampling.
Experience Sampling is what's
called a strategic research
technique, and it's
strategic because it's
looking at uncovering
user needs.
It's not evaluating
a product or a design
that we currently have.
So in the DIN project,
what we did is this:
we asked people the same
question over and over again,
what did you want
to know recently?
And we saw this-- I
can't share the data
and the size doesn't
really represent the data,
but we have two
parts of answers.
One part is what
people search on Google
that they shared with us.
And there's another
part of what people
want to know that Google
can't give them today.
And these are two examples.
What they do on Google is things
like-- not just of course,
but-- Barack Obama height.
And Google is very
good with thousands
of types of questions
or queries such as that.
But they also want to know for
example, what type of writer
am I?
Google can't give
this to them today.
So all of this, what people
want to know that they can't
do today, is an
opportunity for us.
And this is extremely
indicative of user needs.
Experience Sampling is
a research technique
where you interrupt
people's daily lives
and ask them to note it,
note their experience
about something.
In our case, this was what
did you want to know recently.
It's very good for identifying
needs, for understanding what
features people need--
OK, not comparing feature
lists to competition-- and for
uncovering current pain points
and delights.
Here are the ingredients.
This is what you need to do
to run an Experience Sampling
study, and it's not really hard.
First, you need to
very carefully think
about the question
that you're asking.
It's really, really important.
Again in our example,
we asked, what
did you want to know recently?
We also asked-- this
was the lead question.
We also asked some
more questions.
For example, why?
Because some
answers, we learned,
are not really telling us a lot.
I'm going to give a
few examples later.
We also ask people for example.
If a picture better explains
your answer, take a picture
and send it to us.
And so on and so forth, and we
asked a few other questions.
Were you with other people?
Or who needed the information?
And so on and so forth.
Generally speaking, we
planned each notification
to take about one
minute to answer--
not about-- up to
one minute to answer.
Because otherwise
people feel overwhelmed.
We asked a question, I don't
know, 5, 8 times a day.
If it's a burden, they
won't participate.
Now there's a question-- how
many times do I ask them?
It depends on how
many answers you want.
And it depends on the activity
that you're looking at.
So for example, if it's what
did you want to know recently,
I claim that people
want to hundreds, maybe
thousands of things
during a typical day.
We only asked a
question 5 or 8 times.
But if it's what was
the reason you recently
updated your website, that might
not happen several times a day.
So you need to kind of do
some reverse mathematics,
and start with how
many answers you
want by the end of the study.
Let's say you want
2,500 answers and then
you can start dividing.
Let's say you have
100 participants
and then you decide
that, OK I'm going
to send it to them 5
times a day for 5 days.
Then you get to 2,500.
Of course some of them
will be garbage and things
you don't understand, but
this is how you calculate it.
Carefully choose a medium.
Text messaging, email,
an app, a phone message.
You can call them, or ask
them to call you and leave
a message.
These are all valid ways.
The primary thing you need to
do you think about in advance
is, how are you going
to collect the data?
Because if it's a text
message that you then
need to copy and paste
into a spreadsheet,
that's not going to work
with 2000 responses.
So think of a good
way to do that.
Ask them to fill a form with
one question or something
like that, and then it
goes into a spreadsheet.
Or if you are more
capable, you can
use [INAUDIBLE] if you heard
about it, and things like that.
But think about it in advance.
Don't find yourself copying
and pasting 2000 responses.
We used Paco.
Paco is an app, an
Android app for sure.
I'm not sure if there's
an iOS version yet.
I know they're working
on it or worked on it.
Publicly available.
Paco goes stands for
Personal Analytics Companion,
and also the name of the
dog of the developer.
It's an app that allows us to
send notifications and manage
this whole Experience
Sampling process really easy.
Decide how to collect the
data in a spreadsheet,
or something like that.
Now participants.
I mentioned 100
participants in general.
You need to carefully
think about participants
and what you're going
to do with them.
How many, we talked about that.
Expectations-- they need to
know what you expect of them.
You need to brief them.
Not too much you.
You don't want to give
them examples of answers,
because this way you're only
going to get these examples.
Stay vague with regards to
what you want them to share
or how you want them
to answer, but do
explain that you expect
them to answer each time
and to answer all of the
questions that you ask.
And answer the
question in a way that
will make you understand
what they mean.
Practice.
A couple of days
before the study,
send the question once
and see what you get.
And if there are participants
who are not really giving you
what you want, work
with them on that.
Give them an incentive.
An incentive-- at Google we pay.
But we have money to pay and I
know a lot of small companies
don't have the money to pay.
To them I say incentive
is not necessarily money.
If you're a start-up,
a small start-up,
if you have an
office, create a wall
of fame of people who
helped us with research.
Put their names on it.
Take a picture and
send it to them.
People love their name.
That would be a great incentive.
If you don't have an
office, have a web page
for that, the wall fame
of study participants
who helped us on your site.
The moment you're
thinking about research
in general and Experience
Sampling specifically
because it involves a
lot of participants,
start recruiting them.
Find them, start finding them.
There are ways to do that.
I'm not going to
describe that now
because it's going
to take a while,
but start recruiting
your participants as
soon as possible.
Recruiting, finding people
to participate in research
is the biggest
bottleneck of research.
Let's talk about the analysis.
We talked about how we
collect the data, who we do it
to with and what
you do with them.
Let's talk a little
bit about the analysis.
So you need to
decide on categories
that you're going to
classify the data.
So imagine you're
getting 2000 responses
and we need to do
something with them.
What you do is classified them
into different categories.
We had-- in the Daily
Information Needs study,
we had 40 plus categories.
Before we even started, we
defined with real specifics,
what are the
categories and what are
the options in each category.
Let's say, let's
take an example.
Let's say this is our Experience
Sampling question: what
frustrated you the last time
you went grocery shopping?
So here are some categories.
So location could
be one category.
Where the frustration
took place,
and options might
be the ones you
see here-- home, way to from
store, in car, parking lot,
and at store.
Another category would
be close people, friends
and family who
might be involved.
Spouse, roommate, kids.
Another one would be
people at the store.
So you look at each
response and you classify it
by these categories.
I'm going to show you how
you do that in a second.
So people at the store could
other customers, cashier,
store service personnel,
and so on and so forth.
And what was the issue?
Finding items, understanding
costs, and long lines.
This is just an example.
So what you do with
it, you classify
each and every response.
Let's say this is
one of the responses.
OK.
I asked a question.
What frustrated you in your
recent grocery shopping
experience?
And this is one answer.
A slow cashier combined
with an elderly person
was in front of me
on the line caused
me to be late to pick
up my son from school.
All right, so how do
you classify that?
So the location is at the store.
Close people are kids.
People at the store are other
customers and the cashier,
and the issue was long lines.
So you kind of disassemble
each and every response
into its components.
As you do that, you learned
that your pre-defined categories
are not so good.
Sometimes you need
to merge them,
sometimes you need
to split them,
to create new ones,
sometime you need
to get rid of a few.
That's fine, do that.
Clean the data as you go.
"Dogs" is an answer we
got to the question what
did you want to know recently.
We have no idea
what "dogs" mean.
So you need to clean this data.
This is an answer to the
frustration at the grocery
store question.
It has nothing to do with what
you need, so clean that data.
And generate-- what?
AUDIENCE: She needs help.
TOMER SHARON: She
needs help, yes.
Yes.
And then you can
generate frequency charts
based on your classification.
You're kind of reassembling
the data in a meaningful way.
So you know what happened most.
So maybe if long lines
is the main problem,
maybe you need to do
something about it.
And you'll see that you will
very quickly identify things
and what you need to do.
Another way of
doing that is what's
called eyeballing the data.
Just reading the
responses gives you
a lot of information
and understanding
about what happened there.
This is an example.
These are our responses
to this question, what
was the reason you recently
used a piece of paper
to write something down?
And this is how you very quickly
eyeball the data into groups.
Some people are making lists,
some people are writing ideas,
some people are sketching stuff.
If you want to read
more about this--
you know almost nothing
about Experience Sampling
at this point.
If you want to read more about
it, this is a book I recommend.
The last guy there
is a TED speaker.
He speaks about
other things at TED.
He speaks about flow, but
this is a really good book
to understand
Experience Sampling.
One second.
So Experience Sampling is
what's called reality mining.
You mine the reality
of your users.
It helps you fall in love
with the problem, which
is critical to solving a real
problem that people care about.
And I know this is the
distribute sandbox,
so let's make at least
one connection here.
If you solve a real
problem people care about,
I think it's very helpful
in terms of distribution.
So last thought--
don't just believe
everything I say
because I stand here.
Try it out on your own.
It's almost as
easy as it sounds.
Thank you.